every individual has his or her own dream
of what's ahead the dreams vary of course
depending on the individuals age occupation and
missions these three for example Bobby singer
Mary Bryan John Norton Bob is exactly 17 years old
now that's an age that doesn't look far ahead he's
captain of the team and he's anxious to make a
good showing Bobby's future looks pretty secure
at the moment John Norton is a lot older than
Bobby singer as a matter of fact he'll be 57
next week John's are realistic down-to-earth
fellow he knows the future holds no miracles
for him but he doesn't particularly care John
is happy with what he's doing and all he asks of
tomorrow is that it be like today John Norton's
future safe and secure or so it would seem
very Brian is 61 and because of painful arthritis
has had to retire after 25 years of
useful employment as a schoolteacher
this was her past
is this her future sitting in the park a
schoolteacher wants to enjoy a well-earned
retirement an energetic man wants to keep working
and active a young fella would like very much
to win a basketball game let's move ahead a few
weeks to the day of Bobby singers basketball game
Bobby's future was all planned but he didn't
anticipate an automobile accident I do Lindbergh
Lindbergh double cross panting one almost tied
up yes there's a volcano Peter says he now stands
at the ball about death I waiting first man to
pick him up gives to whiffle whiffle out here at
the 10-second line take the pass into the center
still holding the ball against the dobbert Robert
take the top the Lindbergh come here on the back
and the give and go doesn't do it quietly Fugazi
for John Norton the future held something even
more serious he became a victim of stroke one
quick moment of time separated him from the work
and activity he thrived on he sees he hears he
understands but his speech centers have been
affected and one side of his body is paralyzed
sitting in the park and painting was to Mary
Bryan really a compromise an acceptable substitute
for a busy teachers existence what she did not
anticipate was that the same crippling arthritis
which motivated her retirement from teaching might
also deprive her of even this simple pleasure
the future for Mary John and Bobby looks black but
that seemingly black future is no more definite
and was the bright outlook they had before they
were struck down for today not only these three
but millions of physically handicapped Americans
even those who've been bedridden for years can
be set on the road back to a full and fruitful
life the most important thing they must learn
is to help themselves and who is to teach them
this lesson it might very well be you you might
be Bobby's mother mrs. singer faced with the
challenge of getting a temporarily handicapped
teenager back into action fortunately it's a
challenge that mrs. singer has been trained
to face and Bobby has already started helping
himself no matter how extensive the injury the
patient should be encouraged to do as much for
himself as his condition permits for a parent
like Beth singer this takes courage it's often
easier and faster to do things for the disabled
than to stand by and watch but letting the patient
do for himself is always the wisest course Karen
the hospital was the first step on the road
back for Bobby then at home his mother saw
to it that his friends pushed him along a little
farther this attention helps the time pass quickly
now she's ready with another step
forward therapeutic exercise as
ordered by the doctor to speed Bobby's
recovery it is vital now that the full
cast has been removed that his muscles be
restored to peak efficiency muscles atrophy
get weak and flabby from disuse the only
prevention exercise this strengthens leg
muscles exercising lower extremities
firms thighs legs and buttock muscles
the process of self-help contains its
own built-in magic every step forward
automatically opens a wider door to
greater and greater accomplishment
now just a short time later Bobby
singer can do far more complicated
exercises by himself and these simple
exercises have strengthened his muscles
surgery and skilled hospital care were only
the beginning it was essential that good
physical care and psychological reinforcement
were continued at home Bobby now has the will
to win their desire to return to his own special
world thanks to his mother's home nursing skills
Bobby singer is on his way back to a full useful
life a successful self-help program builds on a
triple foundation motivation exercise and
hope hope an important word it's easy it's
natural to be hopeful when you're seventeen but
when you're 61 her doctor prescribed drugs heat
treatments and exercise but Mary Bryan does not
realize that exercise is often a key to self-help
actually exercise had been helping Mary
for years although she didn't know it
our work as a school teacher involved
constant exercise she bent stretched
reached played the piano moved about she
felt occasional twinges but she couldn't
stop long enough to feel sorry for herself
her constant activities supplied the exercise
that prevented stiffening of joints and
shortening of muscles it kept her going
once she retired she weighed and measured her
movements against the pain they might involve
a lovely spring day outside but was it worth
the pain it might cost her to walk to the door
it would be fun to model with clay again but
again she considered the pain and the fact
that now she could not use her hands as well as
she used to perhaps a cup of tea no she would
until finally there came a time when she was
scarcely moving at all and this was the vicious
circle the lack of movement crippled her so
much that the very thought of exercise seemed
unbearable is there any hope for Mary Brian there
might be no I'm not thinking of a new wonder drug
though that's always a possibility I'm thinking
of something closer to home someone you might know
perhaps I'm thinking of you if you were trained
in home nursing skills you'd be equipped to
accept the challenge of Mary's problem you might
even be knocking at her door this very moment
you would know that whether the handicap
stems from accident sickness or old age
the fundamental objective is constant to restore
the patient to self-sufficiency as soon
as possible you could provide Mary with
the encouragement she needs so desperately
you could reaffirm her need for exercise
perhaps you would start Mary's self-help program
by getting her back to the activity that provided
her with so much pleasure modeling with clay
and painting and once you had accomplished this
he would keep encouraging her expanding
her range of activities flexibility of
joints will return gradually with continuing
exercise household chores provide excellent
exercises if they're started slowly and a
bit more is done each day such as sweeping
dishwashing
and ironing
eventually there would come a day when the
results of your efforts would bear fruit the
drug therapy the heat and exercise that you
suggested will help limber her muscles and
joints and help prevent progressive stiffening
shortening and crippling Mary Brian would have
been on the road back and you would have played
a substantial part in putting her on that road
two days ago John Norden was stricken at home
his right side is paralyzed his speech centers
affected in stroke the importance of basic
preventive procedures to avoid crippling and
the wasting away of good muscle from disuse cannot
be overstressed for even in stroke practically no
victim need become helpless deformed or bedridden
for the rest of his life if rehabilitation starts
immediately although mrs. Norton has taken
a home nursing course she needs to know more
about special exercises needed joint supports and
correct body posture a public health nurse helps
with this continuing process of rehabilitation
begun by mrs. Norton following the doctor's orders
she positions John Norton's extremities to prevent
muscle shortening the paralyzed patient must have
the affected parts supported because arms and legs
tend to turn causing deformity supports such as
pillows hand rolls blankets towels and sandbags
will hold the extremities in proper position
always try to place the patient in an easy
natural position and provide support wherever
it's needed this will relieve strain on any
part of the body and prevent deformities
keep the body in good alignment change
the patient's position frequently also
needed is a foot board higher than the toes
the patient's feet should rest comfortably
with toes pointing up this will prevent
shortening of the heel cord or foot drop
simple procedures like these get the patient
off to an excellent start toward rehabilitation
since a stroke victim may suffer from
incontinence both urinary and bowel it
is important to train the patient to use
a bedpan thus helping to keep the skin
dry and so avoid the formation of pressure
sores frequent change of position bathing
back rubs and the use of various bed pads
such as easily washed sheepskin with the
police uppermost will help keep the patient
comfortable and the skin in good condition
48 hours later the next phase for John
Norton was ordered by the doctor exercise
simple range of motion exercises of both
the weak and the unaffected extremities
keep the joints in hands arms legs feet
and hips from getting stiff they can be
carried out efficiently by the home nurse
after instruction by a professional person
next when the patient is well enough he starts
his own exercise at first it is difficult but
each day has strengths returns the task
becomes simpler and the horizons wider
mrs. Norton's home nursing instruction
has taught her another important point
to support the patient's emotional needs she
knows the importance of the will to recover
the desire to be independent the patients
need to know that he is still a respected
individual she lets him know that though
communication is now slow and difficult she
is still anxious to share his world with him
several weeks later we see John Norton using
devices that make self-help possible this
pulley and rope for example helped him to
exercise both arms there are side rails
for the bed so that he can turn himself
two strong household chairs can be an
improvised tool to help him regain his
lost balance by shifting his weight from
one foot to another over and over again
yes John Norton is taking his first step on
the tedious road to recovery many self-help
devices can be bought borrowed or rented from
manufacturers rehabilitation centers and public
welfare and other community resources
these devices range from wheelchairs
to special clothing without zippers or
buttons there are special Forks and spoon
suction cups for dishes and many others
they're all designed to restore the
patient to maximum independence in the
shortest possible time these items can
help to get a handicap patient into an out
of a bathtub and this a sturdy dining room
chair with wheels or casters added
to provide mobility this improvised
wheelchair will move and turn easily and it
will fit through a narrower bathroom door
mrs. Norton knows that a tub bath will give
John's morale a boost and her training as a
home nurse has acquainted her with the correct
procedures she places the chair so the patient
faces the side of the tub and leaves enough
space so that his legs can be raised into the
tub bracing the chair firmly she helps the patient
lift one leg at a time over the tub when his legs
are inside the tub she moves the chair close
to the tub the patient utilizes the grab bars
to help himself off the chair and onto the edge
of the tub as he works his way onto the stool
mrs. Norton provides assistance only where it is
necessary he places his feet on the rubber mat
a sling for the weak arm often
helps the patient with his balance
for John Norton there is the joy of once again
being able to help himself for mrs. Norton a
share in that joy and the pride and satisfaction
of knowing how much she has contributed we've
seen how valuable home nursing skills can be in
the area of the home helping friends neighbors
loved ones on a broader level looking toward the
unforeseeable future these skills might someday
be a national asset a reservoir of strength and
capability that could help us survive as a nation
in a community shelter those with training
as home nurses can go about the business of
helping the handicapped and the sick back to
health as quickly as possible even though well
on the way to recovery the stroke victim can
become a total invalid unless exercises are
continued the home nurse is aware of this had
John Norton been a disaster victim mrs. Norton
could have continued his rehabilitation as
has been said rehabilitation considers not
what is lost but what is left and tries to
make the most of it we don't know whether
we'll ever face a national emergency but
we can predict the future for John Norton
for John Norton work of a less
demanding nature but still
providing the satisfaction of a useful existence
and for a Bobby singer a gradual return to his
active life or Mary Bryan a world enlarged rather
than diminished it can be done with a little
patience common sense and the knowledge that
comes with home nursing skills John Norton Bobby
singer Mary Bryan and millions of others can find
the road back the next film in this home nursing
series will deal with that invaluable commodity
water we'll learn how it relates to cleanliness
and health and how the home nurse can make a
little bit go a long way in the meantime we'd
like to refer you to this Red Cross home nursing
textbook it's available at bookstores and at Red
Cross chapters it contains much of the material
covered in this series in more detail it's a
good reference book to have in the home you